[Musique]
c'est vrai que la montagne est belle
même en hiver mais cela ne suffit pas à
retenir les jeunes ariège un pays vieux
évident 28 habitants km car elle 59 en
midi pyrénées c'est pas la joie pour
tout le monde dans ce département vidé
de sa substance
demandez donc aux célibataires et puis
ceux qui s'étaient accrochés à leurs
vieilles montagnes les vivre un jour
arriver d'ailleurs de n'importe où et de
plus loin encore personne ne les
connaissait il avait l'air bizarre
il aimait le voyage et pourtant ils
firent halte dans ce pays qui n'en
croyait pas ses yeux c'était dans les
années 70 certains ont alors oublié de
repartir petit à petit ils ont pris
racine dans ces terres dur à vivre et
attachante comme un amour incertain eux
ce sont les hippies les cheveux lui les
déguiser les indiens les néo ruraux
comme les appellent les services
officiels
ils sont 200 300 peut être un millier
dans ces montagnes de l'ariège une
véritable colonie de repeuplement que
les comptables d'état ont du mal à
répertorier
qu'importe il redonne vie
[Musique]
certains appellent jimmy l'américain tu
préfères le nom de caubeyres ours
corbeau en français il vient des states
mais voilà trois ans qu'il a planté ses
rêves dans la montagne
en fait je fais de la charpenterie par
nécessité parce que je me refais une
maison mais je la prends la charpenterie
depuis deux ans et je me considère pas
charpentier mais ça vient sinon je fais
de l'artisanat du cur des proverbes
encadrer certains de l'artisanat quoi ça
suffit pas vivre ça peut a priori oui
à priori oui on finit tueur
on a toujours de quoi vivre quand même
[Musique]
ici chacun tente de vivre sa vie seul ou
avec les autres qu'on a bien du mal à
voir d'ailleurs dès que se lève la brume
sur la montagne
mais à l'occasion cela n'empêche pas le
cérémonial du pain tout un symbole
ça fait 17 ans que tu arrives ici
commencer enfin pas si vous faites tous
les combien le début on faisait ainsi
régulièrement puis après on sait
maintenant c'est plus ou moins réguliers
continue comme ça parce que tu vas
chercher ben là où c'est parce que rafa
toute façon on a notre contact on a eu
notre contact avec le blé avec la farine
est fixée comme enjeu c'est autre chose
quoi quelques déchets c'est vrai que
vous faites pour la maison ici ou pour
plusieurs maisons pour plusieurs maisons
dont trois où ce n'est pas par des gens
qui viennent de participer ce suivant
qu'ils ont le temps on vend une chose à
faire mais c'est pas avec votre ampli
non non c'est du bruit comme lâcheté
qu'on a fait moudre au moulin quoi cette
chance là encore on va faire ça et puis
comme la maison était équipée d'un fou
aussi alors on a on va profiter et de
quoi vous fait de l'élevage
voilà quelques chauffage un troupeau de
chiens ces bombes servant à gerland vie
à la survie mais enfin nous on n'est pas
ici pour faire la rentabilité quoi ouais
ici le point de recharge d'un mode de
vie différent afin de mettre des vicois
sur l'échéance a démoli tout dans le
paysage ses côtés le coton est arrivé
ici avec eux des fougères d'errance des
sorties je n'ai fait aucune des salles
et apparemment il avait que des chefs
qui fait quoi du fromage avec mes chiens
désolé moi vivre autrement réinventer
l'habitat avec les moyens du bord ce qui
donne à la montagne un petit air
cosmopolite
certains ont fait des choix encore plus
surprenant habiter une tante indienne
par exemple comme michel qui a choisi de
vivre dans un tipi copiés sur ceux des
tribus causes profondes prédestiné
conserver ou celui interdisant toute
façon ça veut dire quoi être inquiet
dans une autre vie c'est tout beau fixe
en différents noms of tout le monde est
différent comme les indiens disait le
droit le droit la différence aussi
important le droit l'égalité c'est vrai
est ce que cette différence est comprise
ici est ce que les gens de la région
facile pour les gens d'ici zemmouri
bien qu'il ya des gens sont usés qui
nous a ouvert le jardin il évalue le
coût à discuter le voisin calogero 6 ils
comprennent bien que tu puisse vivre
autrement bien parce qu'ils savent pas
c'est qu'il en a plein qui vivent comme
ça autour sont les voix profondes
réformes n'ont pas très loin d'ici
vous êtes combien à vivre dans des
tentes et j'en sais rien les rencontres
de temps à autre à temps en temps les
gens qui sont passés et des gens vous
voient depuis longtemps sur le marché
tout ça
le samedi le lundi pourquoi que choisit
variés voici selon comme histoire par
hasard en fait parce qu'on en était on
était membre d'une bande à brest et puis
on est descendu dans le sud petit à
petit pour pour travailler pour changer
d'air pour le soleil il travaillait
faire des fruits faire des trucs comme
ça le vendent aux petit à petit on s'est
fixé à 5 ans une dernière question
pourquoi tu t'es mis si près des
villages parce que mon atelier l'europe
mégots sont vides
à l'origine il eu les communautés on
vivait ensemble on travaillait ensemble
en laver son linge sale en commun
difficile l'expérience a rarement
survécu aux désillusions des années 70
il ya des communautés mais il y en a qui
vivent plutôt dans une maison ou dans
des hameaux où chacun à son foyer
vous préférez travailler comme ça dis
moi vous rencontrer à l'occasion de
cette existe aw sûr il ya des fêtes
le pôle est pleine lune pour le solstice
d'été les solstices d'hiver pour des
anniversaires pour les enfants quand on
fait du pain qu'est ce que vous faites
là vous chantez vous danse et la musique
de la danse
mais il ya un temps pour tout même ici
et les artisans comme jean-louis
réinvente les règles de la production et
du commerce
ben on fait des faits donc des choses
pour les enfants ont déjoué des choses
comme ça des marionnettes
on fait aussi des des des pancartes
publicitaires pour les magasins ont fait
de la décoration de magasins ont fait
des affiches pour des pour des pour
n'importe quoi plutôt j'avais une
affiche ou bien pour fausses idées des
cartes de visites ou de la décoration de
camions voitures de motos autre chose
comme ça il ya longtemps que tu fais ça
voilà ça fait trois mois que j'installe
atelier autrement ça fait cuire et plus
longtemps que c'est ça ça donne quoi
mais j'ai travaillé sérieusement depuis
depuis quatre mois quoi jusqu'au stade
ultime celui de l'entreprise
nicolas qui fabrique avec ses associés
des poutres de cheminée and a fait le
pari sont d'une société de fer avec dont
trois responsables donc on appelle ça
les patrons mais non
voudrait le plus vite possible arrivée à
une entreprise autogérée par tous les
personnels et à travailler qu'avec des
gens qui s'intéressent à ce qu'on fait
parce qu'on veut être un patron pour
accumuler de l'argent en exploitant les
autres on peut aussi être patron pour
les autres sans l'être soi même les
hippies c'est fini t'oublies iep être
branché un argot américain
initiation et rites mais cela at il un
jour vraiment commencé en france pour ce
corbeau avec lui le mouvement aux usa y
en a conservé deux vérité l'amour les
philosophies mystique spirituel de
plusieurs cultures
il s'en séparait il se disant que c'est
un repos c'est pas la même chose
c'est toujours la même chose car on vu
sous le soleil là le c'est important les
éléments ceux qui nous gouvernent
ouais mais ici on a dit que c'était des
hippies qui était dans la montagne est
ce que tu te considères comme un hippie
pas nécessairement non en tant
qu'américain oui en tant que français
n'en qui peut expliquer cette différence
ouais c'est que la france c'est un pays
rural
a priori ce pas le far west
loin de ça et le mouvement est terminé
dans la sauce tient à conserver quand
même un peu les et décoration jouets
tombant talent est là ça c'est pas une
décoration et puis c'est une décoration
amérindienne qui est vieille de 200 ans
comme la comme le serpent réunies ou aux
mondiaux l'anglais the united states
1 les indiens ça joue un rôle important
quand même
votre avis pour l'amérique oui pour la
france c'est peut-être du folklore et
mythologie mais l'europe est fou de
l'amérique l'amérique c'est une terre
rouge indienne center où jouent et
amérindiennes ici on est rural un peu
marginale on aime les plaisirs simples
ce qui n'empêche pas la gendarmerie
d'inspecter les récoltes tous les
automnes histoire de faire la chasse à
l'herbe à la drogue comme disent les
journaux à sensation moi je viens d'un
pays qui est le plus grand importateur
de drogue du monde est là qu'est ce qui
vaut plus cher au kilo que l'or ou leurs
agneaux
c'est l'héroïne l'héroïne c'est une
drogue de ville ici en a pas parce
qu'ici c'est une bulle
c'est un peu une survie d'une sélection
naturelle tu es obligé de faire ton bois
pour se chauffer tu vois il y en a pas
ici de l'euro ouais il viendra d'où ce
nom trop de l'air le tatoué de
l'actionner qu'une plante et crois moi
elle est vieille comme le monde
l'ariège ce n'est pas forcément le bout
du chemin plutôt une étape pour ces gens
qui ont quitté parfois emploi famille et
sécurité partie de leur bretagne ou de
leurs alsace pour la quête d'autres
choses d'une autre vie de même souvent
vocation c'est de travailler avec des
horaires précis c'est un patron pillé
puis s'emmerder trop souvent quoi la
location c'est donc de faire quelque
chose quelque chose tout seul à le faire
quelque chose de savoir moyens quoi mais
tu as envie de ça ah oui bien sûr ça
commençait à lui zine alors garé dans le
ciel bleu à travers les vitres
j'ai eu envie de partir bah ouais pas
dans l'avenir pour nous ça tu t'es où je
te la malheureuse dans l'armement
comment justement tilleuls
et puis j'ai traîné mes guêtres parce
que je voulais pas me plier aux
exigences de notre monde est petit à
petit je me suis retrouvé dans l'ariège
et puis j'ai trouvé que le pays était
bien moins et on l'a essayé de vivre en
se passant un peu d des lois du système
et tout ça et on s'est rendu compte
qu'on s'est très vite heurtés au système
qui existait même dans cette petite
vallée perdue en seconde qu'on ne
demandait qu'une chose c'est nous c'est
de vivre tranquillement en essayant de
vivre avec la nature sera du compte ce
n'est pas possible
puis on s'est dit qu'en fin de compte on
pouvait aussi de faire autre chose
un dieu arrivé ici est ce que tu te
définis c'est comme ça que les gens
appeler non moi j'étais moi j'étais je
suis venu ici comme ça émet hippie c'est
les gens qui nous appeler comme ça parce
qu'on a les cheveux longs c'est tout ben
je crois que c'est tout pour eux
maintenant nous
est ce qu'on sait vraiment ce que ça
veut dire être hippie je sais pas mais
ça ça veut bien dire que les cheveux
longs il ya une quinzaine d'années
disque un an
ça voulait dire beaucoup de choses ça
voulait dire se démarquer d'un système
qu'on refuse elle est aujourd'hui c'est
aujourd'hui c'est une mode
tout le monde a les cheveux longs
pourquoi tu les as encore elle va parce
que je me trouve au début le contact
avec les populations locales ne fut pas
à vraiment facile mais les choses
s'arrangent peu à peu les ariégeois de
souche découvre que ce petit monde n'est
pas fait que de parasites comme on le
croyait naguère on les disait est
chômeur professionnel
même les services officiels
reconnaissent que le pointage à l'anpe
n'est pas le fort des néoruraux pour eux
la vie ne commence pas forcément dans
les files d'attentes de la sécu ou du
chaume du je suis un travailleur
saisonnier
ça me permet bien sûr de d'avoir de
l'argent pour ne pas donner de travaux
et mes outils et ainsi de suite
mais sinon bon que je la sécu c'est
important c'est tout ce qui m'intéresse
en fait c'est pour ça que le chômage on
n'est pas besoin la ville si je meurs
demain je serai plus là mais le chemin
est tout à fait il est devant moi ta vie
tes données folle à vue et c'est ici
qu'on a fait un chemin une partie du
chemin pour le pas le chemin que j'ai à
faire en ce moment parce que dans cinq
ans de suspension
[Musique]